governor sissel act was in town today to  talk with local culinary workers about  the recent bills he signed into law  during the 81st  legislative session namely senate bill  386  known as the right to return law which  gives workers who were laid off after  the 12th of march last year because of  pandemic related economic problems  the right to go back to work starting  july 1st  as long as there is one of your brothers  and sisters that hasn't gotten their job  back we're not finished  we've got to bring everybody back  everyone that wants to come back to work  deserves the  dignity deserves a respect to be able to  return  to put things into perspective 98  percent of the culinary union's members  were unemployed following last year's  shutdowns  let's fast forward to now only about 50  percent are back to work  the governor says he's doing everything  in his power to empower people  to get back to work and build our  economy back better